brad pitt got a little emotional taking
part in a buddhist ritual at the temple
in tokyo as part of promotion for his
latest blockbuster bullet train brad was
a part of the ceremony explaining why he
was moved by the whole experience take a
look and we'll see you next time
you know we thought it would be a fun
thing to do because the character in the
film ladybug is uh thinks he has bad
luck
and uh he's coming to terms with that in
the film
but i i have to tell you me myself i was
really moved in there it's
when it's so beautiful
the the temple itself is so beautiful
the
the monks themselves were beautiful
and
i i don't know i almost got teary i was
really moved by it so i i really thank
you for the experience and and uh it's
one that i that i will not forget this
is just one more example for me of just
how beautiful it is here how beautiful
the culture is and i just
to everyone out there i just say thank
you every time i come here it's so warm
and loving and i just i just have this
sense of freedom here so
my message is thank you domo origato